[Music]
Alana Honey Boo Boo Thompson goes to
prom oh my sound it is the best out
there I'm the drippiest person ever oh
the 17 year old came dripping with her
look to the big dance in Georgia Alana
posing with her mom mama June Shannon
and stepdad Justin Stroud while rocking
a pink ball gown with sparkling crystals
a sight all too familiar from Alana's
pageant past
come on
in another pre-prom snap Alana stands
next to her 21 year old boyfriend dralen
Carswell a moment Fit For A Princess as
it's topped with a white horse-drawn
carriage with pink accents made for a
grand entrance it's like I'm dating my
best friend now like I tell him
everything we do everything together
prior to the dance Alana teased the
glamorous look in a series of selfies
showing off her hair and nails but it's
a certain rock on that finger that's
catching eagle-eyed fans attention yeah
that is a diamond on her left ring
finger now E.T has reached out to
Alana's team for comet
aside from an engagement possibly being
on the table one thing is for sure
Alana's got big plans for her future so
are you ready for your senior year oh
yes I am more than ready last year the
reality star opened up to E.T about her
goals After High School I definitely
wanted to go to College full-time
because I want to be a neonatal nurse so
I want to go to college and so I can be
a neonatal nurse what what and then we
helped him baby yeah oh look
for sure I love little babies well I
think you got a whole house full right
here to play right do you have your eyes
on
it well there's only one school I have
my eyes on and it's like Riggs
University and that's in Denver but
other than that all right
other than that no they no I don't have
any other social Norm is big enough for
me to fit in there in the meantime seems
Alana is enjoying her last months of
senior year the best way she knows how
in style and Pretty in Pink from head to
toe
foreign